There's a lot of  misinformation out there about what it means to be a transgender
but recently,
Scientists have begun to look more closely
into the Neurology, Physiology, and Psychology
behind it.
So today, we're gonna break down what Science does knows
in a respectful and educational way.
Hey guys! I'm Gigi Gorgeous
And today, I'm here with ASAPScience
to break down 'The Science of Being a Transgender'
Before we get to deep into it,
we have to look at your genetic sex.
Or the chromosomes you have.
These were determined right after fertilization.
When the sperm cell from your father
which carries an 'X' or a 'Y' chromosome
fuse with the egg from your mother, which carries an 'X' chromosome.
But until 6 or 7 weeks after fertilization,
both 'XY' and 'XX' embryos
have identical gonads.
Around 7 weeks
the male sex organs start to develop
because of  a gene on 'Y' chromosome
called 'SRY'
It causes cells to become more specialized
and these cells creates 'Testosterone'
which in turns trigger the development
of the structure like the
penis and scrotum.
While other cells block female development
by the degenerating the female ducts
However, in female development
because there is no 'Y' chromosome with the 'SRY' gene.
These ducts stay intact and become the uterus
cervix, upper vagina, and the oviduct
with the help of Estrogen, and chemicals secreted by
the early kidney.
But it's not always that simple.
There are some times even when RARE COMBINATIONS
like 'XXY', 'XXX' 'XXYY' etc.
And even people with
'XX" Chromosomes that develop male genitals and characteristics
Due to a piece of the 'Y' chromosome breaking off,
and switching places to an 'X' chromosome.
But SEXUAL DIFFERENTIATION in a brain,
actually happens much later than Gonadal Differentiation.
And yes, although controversial
Male and Female brains have
structural and functional diffrences
between each other.
Studies have found that
males generally have a larger cerebrum
cerebellum.
and hippo campus.
While females have
higher density left frontal lobe,
and larger volumes in the right frontal lobe.
So what exactly do we see
when we look in the brain
of a transgender person?
Several studies have shown that
transgender brains are both
structural and functionally more
similar to their experienced gender identity
than their biological sex.
One study found that transwomen who
despite being assigned male at birth
had a smaller female size structure in the hypothalamus.
MRI scans also show the
brain structures of trans people
to be more similar in thickness into their
experienced gender and not their sex.
Finally the pheromone Androstadienone causes
different hypothalamic responses in male & female brains
And when the individuals  with 'Gender Dysphoria' were exposed to it,
the hypothalamic response match their Perceived gender rather than their sex.
These studies help to highlight masculinisations
or feminisations of the Gonads
is not always the same as the brain
and that there's a difference between
your sex or your anatomy
and your gender or how you perceived your own body.
There also seems to be
a genetic component to transgender identity.
Looking at family histories,
gender identity in congruence seems to run in the family,
meaning they maybe inherited
The 'CYP17' gene which controls
the body's level of sex hormones
has a changed allele that is expressed
frequently in trans man.
Although more research could be done,
scientists are currently at looking at over
3 Million DNA Markers for transgender identity
to investigate any genetic link for being trans.
Even though scientific studies
validate the experience of transgender people
there's still suffering from more
depression and anxiety than the general public.
The risk of suicide
is more prominent in transgender people
who have been rejected by their family
discriminated in their workplace,
or in health care.
Sucide risks seems to
decreased after gender transitioning.
Suggesting that gender dysphoria can cause
an extreme amount of emotional pain
even to the point of suicide.
If you, a family member, or a friend is
suffering from gender dysphoria ,
there are few links in the description
for more information.
Thank you so much Gigi
for being part of this video,
it means so much and we're happy that you were here to do this with us.
GIGI: Ah, thank you guys for using
your channel, your platform
validating transgender experiences with science
which is brings closer to equality.
Mitch: Absolutely
If you guys wanna check out Gigi's Channel
we'll put links in the description
or in the screen somewhere.
Otherwise, you can subscribe for more Science here
every week, and we'll see you next time.
PEACE!